a lo largo de este martes se escucharon
los primeros testimonios de las partes
civiles de los atentados de noviembre de
2015 aquí en parís en especial los que
lo que sucedió en el estadio de francia
durante cerca de tres horas seis
gendarmes hablaron recordaron el lo
sucedido esa noche fueron recuerdos
bastante vividos ellos decían que aún
tenían presente el olor en las
explosiones el ruido de esas explosiones
la sangre que había quedan sus uniformes
los restos de cuerpo humano que estaban
en el piso y también pues contaban el
pánico que habían sentido así como las
secuelas a nivel psicológico que les
había quedado muchos de ellos están bajo
el tratamiento farmacológico y esto
también ha tenido un impacto en sus
familias en la segunda parte se
escucharon los testimonios bastante
fuertes primero el de sophie días la
hija de manuel díaz manuel díaz que es
la única víctima mortal de los atentados
en el estadio de francia y espera que la
muerte de su padre no quede en el olvido
y por otra parte vila
un hombre que había estado en este
estadio junto con su hijo estaba en un
restaurante adyacente en esa noche y
pues allí frente a ese restaurante uno
de los kamikaze se hizo explotar y desde
entonces pues el señor moco no está en
una silla de ruedas él fue el único que
osó mirar a los acusados allí a
presentes en esta sala y decirles que no
les perdonaba por lo que habían hecho y
que él como musulmán que es no podía
creer que alguien hiciera tales
atrocidades en el nombre de alá en total
cerca de 340 personas serán escuchadas
aquí en este tribunal en las próximas
cinco semanas